All right.
We're here with Cass and Ted Philpott, and Ell,
who they recently have been upgrading their home,
room by room,
but can't agree to do the same thing in the final room.
Mikel what advice do you give couples, actually,
when it comes to design?
They live in the same space,
but they want different things.
What do you do?
Okay, so this is what I say,
like treating a design is just like a marriage.
It's gotta be some compromise, right?
So I really think that you don't want
more than one person in the room than the other.
So I recommend doing a mood board.
You take three inspirational images.
You take inspirational images.
You put them all on that one board,
and you can at least begin to see what your design style is.
Mood boards are key.
All right.
Mikel and I have taken all the evidence into consideration
and come to a decision.
Here is what the room currently looks like.
Photos please everybody.
There we go.
All right.
Oh the dog.
By the way, the dog stays.
All right, well, Mikel and I have the final verdict.
Are you ready to see everything that we've done
and knowing when you look at it,
every single item in the room has to go back to the store.
So if you don't like it,
it's not a problem.
Sounds fair.
I'm just kidding.
Everything in the room is yours.
Every single item, everything.
(audience clapping)
All right, let's open the doors.
Oh my God.
That's awesome.
Look at the bar.
So ladies.
Why don't you two ladies take a seat here.
And my friend,
since you really wanted a entertainment area,
I'm gonna lay at you hang out over here
so you can get a little more comfortable.
That sounds great.
This is awesome.
Okay, the chairs are on swivels.
Something that we found very key
because you've got your TV here.
So if everybody wants to watch, great.
If everybody wants to make this coffee table,
like for food or games or center point,
then you have this swivel action.
This Pottery Barn farm armchair, like it has a swivel.
It's just amazing.
And it gets you like a little conversational pit, right.
Yes.
Also, they've really camouflaged the swivel.
They have.
You don't, these do not look like swivels,
but they have that surprise in them,
so you know wherever you are.
And then we did a little bar over here
because you could have like sandwiches
and like Coca-Colas with your friends.
Yes.
You can have a beer with your friends.
You can have a cocktail with your friends.
And just like instead of it looking like
kind of like a cheesy bar,
we wanted it to be very neutral and chique.
Well, and then the other thing,
you know, one thing that you love more so
than anything is storage,
but you have like a ton of storage.
Like you guys can house all of your games.
I mean, it's just so much storage here.
Remote controls, posters, and remote controls.
They can start to muck up the room.
So just slide 'em in your leather boxes.
And for all that stuff that you wanna be like
nothing to see here.
'Cause life is messy.
It's real.
And so you gotta have somewhere
to cram all that stuff and hide it.
(audience clapping)
But also this speaks to,
I think the number one thing
that really jumped out at us this week in design week,
the number one trend is that pops of black
are extremely chique.
You have a little black coffee table,
a little black stripe in the rug, a black table, little art.
So Cass, what do you think?
I'm speechless.
This is inspired.
It will give me a space and it also gives them,
it really does mesh both of our visions, I think.
Good job.
Ell, what do you think?
I love it.
And I think my friends will too.
I think we can hang out in here.
It'll be rad.
All right, Ted thoughts.
Truthfully, I love it.
I might even take up reading.
What.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Well, Ted we have one more surprise for you
and the whole family.
So as you picture the room, this is one giant window.
You had a couch in front of it.
Correct.
But what we wanted to do
since we got rid of the couch
was we gave you this amazing, incredible shuffle board game
to place in the way.
No way.
And it is so chique.
It goes right with the wood and the furniture.
I have to say like-
Oh my gosh.
We knew you wanted a game.
Oh and it gets better my friend.
So with this beautiful shuffle board,
you're gonna need to take some type of score
as you're whipping up on these ladies.
So I've created a DIY scoreboard for you
that you'll be able to take home
so that you and the family can keep score
while you're playing.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Look at that.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
That is so amazing.
Okay, what is like one word that comes to mind
when you look at the room?
Cass.
Inspired
Ell.
Amazing.
Ted.
A blend.
Fantastic.
We did it.
And we could have done this without Pottery Barn.
Oh my God.
You are the dream makers that made it happen.
(upbeat music)